kevin is with us in Midland Texas hi
Kevin how are you any better and I it
would be illegal Dave how are you about
the same brother how can I help
well I have a question about my
girlfriend's father he is 56 years old
he has unsteady income roughly about
thirty thousand a year and he doesn't
have any retirement setup yet and we are
worried that if we were to get married
we would be the ones to financially
support him and we would we would just
like your advice on how to handle that
excuse me well I mean I would not allow
that to keep you from getting married
and then as long as the two of you can
make that decision on how much you're
willing to support someone um together
okay is he unable to work or unwilling
uh unwilling he has a he if you want to
call it that he has his own business
where he works on hydraulic machines but
he like from what I gather for my
girlfriend he doesn't uh he doesn't want
to let's say go to Burger King or
Walmart and look for $10 an hour or
something like that he would rather just
sit at home I guess he and he doesn't I
guess he doesn't like to work for other
people he would rather be an own boss
right that's fine as long as I wasn't
out that will yeah that's fine long as
you work more he's not working much
exactly so uh well I think the thing is
this the two of you more than anything
else had to be in agreement on how much
you're going to support this guy so
let's let's fast-forward okay
twenty years from now he's 76 he's ill
he has no money because he's continued
live this way you guys have saved a
million dollars how much are you going
to help him there's not a wrong answer
but that's how you need to think about
it
okay right is it you're sitting there
you've done the smart stuff with money
you've got a million dollars this guy's
been basically lazy most of his life and
now he's in a pinch but it's her dad so
how much are you going to support your
wife's dad that 76 years old that's ill
has not taken care of money has not
worked much and I don't care what you do
and there's not a wrong answer if you
want to be generous and kind and pour a
bunch of money on the guy that would not
be a wrong answer if you want to be a
little tougher and go now you made your
bet dude you lay in it and not do
anything then that's okay too but the
trick is for the two of you as a married
couple to have already decided this like
20 years ahead of time
that make sense okay
yes sir and the two of you are the two
of you're in agreement on it because
it's more concerning to me that the two
of you are in agreement than otherwise
and you know if let's say you're not
willing to help him they later on and
the two of you get married then maybe
she goes and has coffee with their dad
and goes you know dad Kevin and I just
got married we've discussed it I want
you to know well in advance that when
you're 76 and broke because you don't
work much we're not going to support you
we've made that decision I want to let
you know that ahead of time and she can
go do that if that was your decision
okay right if it's not your decision
then you know you don't do that but I
mean you just leave it alone and stand
back and watch him you know he's going
to do what he's going to do I don't know
that you can affect him and the problem
is is that they're stupid and crazy in
almost every family and so you're going
to marry into it and so is she at some
point in some way right I mean it's in
every family and if you think it's not
it's you so it's in every family you
know so you've just identified where it
is in this family ahead of time and you
know you just got to decide what your
boundaries are going to be and then you
know how much in spite of the boundaries
and despite his misbehavior how much you
know grace and generosity financially
that you're going to pour forward and
you know what you're going to what
you're going to be willing to do at that
point and so but I think
that's the thing for the two of you to
talk about but I wouldn't say oh no I'm
not going to get married because I'm
worried we might have to support him
later but we could just look at it and
go we're not gonna support him later so
please get married you know or we're
gonna get married and part of a part of
our walk over the years is we may have
to reach other and take care of dad who
doesn't work so much you know and either
ones okay the trick is to be in
agreement about it and for you to have
her back on this because it's her dad
it's gonna be hard for her to make which
ever decision she makes this is the Dave
Ramsey job
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below